[Musique]
voilà plus de sept ans qu'est née la
renault 5 et avec plus de deux millions
et demi de modèles déjà produit celle
qu'on a nommé la voiture sympa est un
succès mais pour élargir et diversifier
la gamme renault propose aujourd'hui du
nouveau
regardez bien c'est une quatre portes
qui conserve le hayon arrière et reste
pratiquement à la longueur d'origine
trois médecins quand de noter des sièges
plus enveloppants et bien sûr une
meilleure accessibilité arrière ou la
place reste tout de même mesuré mais
renault a voulu faire peau neuve sur
toute la gamme 3 et 5 portes
en présentant une nouvelle planche de
bord à la fois plus pratique plus
moderne et dont l'équipement varie bien
sûr selon les modèles tout ceci avec un
dénominateur commun une insonorisation
enfin améliorés
autre modification la réduction de
l'effort au volant par une plus grande
des multiplications enfin côté
motorisation il ya du nouveau pour
renforcer le caractère économique
renault propose sur les tl et gtl un
moteur 11 145 chevaux spécialement mise
au point la 5 à 5 portes est encore une
réussite esthétique elle est devenue
plus commode pour une famille de 4
personnes et surtout moins brillante et
plus agréable à conduire à titre
expérimental nous avions monté cet
ordinateur geiger de calcul des
consommations
il a permis de constater que les tl et
gtl sont encore plus économique
et si les chiffres officiels 4,9 à 90 ou
si les trois en ville sont tout de même
assez difficile à tenir
félicitons la régie renault qui obtient
là des résultats extrêmement intéressant
cette gt elle cinq portes coûte 29 1400
francs mais la gamme onze modèles
démarre à 22000 50 francs
[Musique]